some of the president's frustrations
over the Russia investigation lie with
Attorney General Jeff Sessions before
leaving Washington on Friday mr. Trump
turned up the heat on sessions and on
the president's political opponents and
a move some say tests the boundaries of
his office Errol Barnett is in our
Washington bureau Errol good morning
good morning
yes while President Trump is away the
ongoing investigation by special counsel
robert muller continues to churn here in
washington but before he left the
commander-in-chief made clear his views
on the Department of Justice's
performance and it's apparent reluctance
to go after his opposition a lot of
people are disappointed in the Justice
Department including me president
Trump's last words before leaving the
White House Friday made his displeasure
with the Justice Department clear all I
can tell you is this
there was no collusion there was no
nothing it's a disgrace frankly that
they continue and as he does repeatedly
via Twitter mr. Trump encouraged the
Justice Department to investigate
Democrats you want to look at Hillary
Clinton and you want to look at the new
book that was just put out by Donna
Brazile fueling the president's argument
is a revelation by the once interim
chair of the Democratic National
Committee donna Brazile Brazil became
the head of the party amid email hacks
coordinated by Russia last year at that
time according to her upcoming book she
discovered an existing signed agreement
where quote in exchange for raising
money and investing in the DNC Hillary
would control the party's finances
strategy and all the money raised she
goes on to write this was not a criminal
act but as I saw it it compromised the
party's integrity we have one area of
disagreement with the secretary the
document was signed by the DNC and the
Clinton campaign in August of 2015 early
in the election cycle when potential
candidates like Vice President Joe Biden
were still deciding whether to get in
form a Bernie Sanders campaign manager
Jeff Weaver what these types of
activities do is destroy the faith of
people
we have a fair and democratic electoral
process now the Clinton campaign said
the DNC was in debt and former chair
governor Howard Dean described the
agreement as standard operating
procedure but as special counsel Muller
continues to bring forward charges
related to Russia Democrats fear
president Trump will continue to exploit
divisions within the party Alex
Errol Barnett in Washington thanks Sarah